I have to tell you it is such a treat
that we get to see you here tonight
celebrating Yellow Jackets how does it
feel to be back with your OG Squad it
feels great I haven't seen these guys in
Forever they've been busy shooting so
yeah it's great everyone looks amazing I
can't wait to see it I'm with you guys I
haven't seen any of it so let's see
we've seen a little and I have to tell
you and I have to thank you it is
excellent and I just want to thank you
for coming back it is you know we we
left season one with saying goodbye to
Jackie I didn't know if we were gonna
get to see you in season two what did it
feel like to step back on that set again
but in ghost form uh it felt good I mean
it was weird because it was a set this
time and not on location they like
rebuilt the cabin you know on a stage uh
so that was it was a blast from the past
it was really weird what were those
scenes like where you're dead and Sophie
Elise has to put makeup on you uh creepy
yeah really creepy
this is a little weird for me yeah it's
weird seeing like your dead self right
in front of you and everyone's like
taking selfies and messing around and
it's like please have some respect for
dead Jackie we do have so much respect
for dead Jackie but you know she has a
really unfortunate outcome what did you
make of the decision to have the Jackie
Feast I saw it coming I'm not gonna lie
yeah
I saw her comment I didn't want to give
away too many of my fan fairies but
that's where we're coming okay so as the
person who is responsible for Jackie are
you okay with that decision I gave you
my full consent
it's our blessing for the cannibalism
just enjoy it a little solo Peppa put me
on the fire it's fine
it was so amazing to get you back in
season two is the door open for season
three
Evie I don't know I would of course I
would I'd do this for 11 Seasons if
they'll have me
you love your girl Jackie I love my gold
jacket I gotta do right by Jackie you
know it's a supernatural show so really
I truly believe anything is possible we
she got charred in season two but maybe
she could come back in season three yeah
his husband my fingers are crossed
[Music]